have you picked up a ps4 Xbox one or
Nintendo switch recently the numbers are
in and only one can take the top spot
I'm Tony and this is your best-selling
game spot news update the Nintendo
switch out sold both ps4 and Xbox one in
the month of March according to game
revolutions report on the latest data
from the NPD group no specific numbers
were given but the same report also says
ps4 outsold Xbox one Sony had no report
of its own but Microsoft released a
statement saying the first quarter of
2017 has been a success with a
record-breaking amount of time spent
globally on Xbox Live so make sure to
LIKE and subscribe to keep up with all
the consoles over the coming months
honestly none of this really surprises
me especially considering the switch is
Nintendo's fastest selling console of
all time in the Americas Europe and
Australia on top of that zelda breadth
of the wild is its best-selling
standalone launch game ever and for even
more of it you can watch Robin Peter
attempt a bunch of crazy Zelda
challenges in our new show the Triforce
[Music]